This is going to be like, what did you and Whitney do,
where you need Kleenexes up your nose? Hi guys.
So we just finished our fist fight. I won
all my blood.
Just used to be a white t-shirt second nose bleed in my life.
And when these beautiful home triggered it triggers,
this is the first time we've actually got to hang out.
One-on-one and I was expecting such a glamorous beautiful
Swan. I'm excited. We're going to be doing,
um, beauty treatment.
Obviously this is perfect for me to die a full face of
makeup. As I apply a face mask to my face, um,
it took like a many tools to apply the layers of
shackle Schlack on my face. It looks great though. It makes me want to sneeze.
If you use any subplot everywhere and it's like, Oh,
you a new towel, but I think there'll be okay. Okay. Do you need his knees?
Uh, all blur this out. Oh, Oh, it's fine. We're good.
If it gets worse, we'll get you a light flow tampon.
That won't be the only place I have one right now. So I have a super,
I thought I was going to be the crass one in this video I'm used to being the
crass one. The sad thing is I don't even know what that means.
It's everything you're doing. You are the embodiment.
I like how I asked Whitney for water earlier and she brought me flavored
sparkling Pellegrino. That's fancy.
And they brought me wine. Oh, wait, I brought her wine.
And then she gave me a gift because she felt obligated because I gave her a
gift. And then she gave me another guest. So one of my guests on top.
So you gave me a wine opener and a candle that I liked that smelled good.
And then you started hemorrhaging from the face? Yeah,
I was over my mind was blown by the wine opener that she showed
me. So I'm really concerned about this. You,
I showed you generosity in your mind. Exploded and you just started bleeding.
I've been in LA for too long. I know. We need to get you some nicer friends.
Yeah. Well now I know where you live. Yeah. You just follow the trail of blood.
Yeah. I feel like we really are becoming friends. I think so. I think you're,
um, me, I thought you were gonna say, I mean, and I was like, Oh. I like,
I got tricked into a call-out video. No, no, no. It's not live.
It's on a camera. I know. It's your kid. You could tackle me.
Delete it from my camera. I can't have you covered in blood,
but just slippery piece of shoe.
But we're the only ones here in the middle of fields and mountains. No,
but you gave me wine. I couldn't catch ya. And that's what you got me all over,
down liquor up. I'm too groggy strategy.
But I do feel like I'm you a little bit. If you're me then I'm you. Yeah.
I'm like you just less bloody. Yeah. Which is great.
You're like the better me than you're saying the bloodless, you know? No.
Even have the same top bun cuter. We use a smoother, you're like the better.
I mean, you're like, um, we're like the before and after mugshot. Okay.
Now we're being nice. This is like,
this is the mugshot for shoplifting.
And this is the mugshot for lighting caught. Shop
the viewers know fully the third wheel on a first day.
Video is not going to do well at all.
Everybody's going to hate it and never want to sit down. Okay.
Let's get some thumbs up masks cleanse face and dry face before using
done called out for that.
I know people get called out for lying and saying, they're not wearing makeup,
but we actually aren't.
I am wearing a full face of literal shoe called can I
use your nose, blood,
just have me over here and bottle my blood and then sell it as your new makeup
line. I think that'd be a hit, bring blood
[inaudible] compliments from lawyers actually. And they're like, Oh,
you should be a lawyer. So maybe really they're flirting with you.
And our elbows are no touching.
I don't know who's going to move the elbow. This is like a game of chicken.
Then I'll play all day long pretending to read this back.
Like we're starting at when he hasn't let me, um,
whoever moves the elbow first is pulling away from this relationship. Yeah.
And you're the reason why he doesn't work out. Whoever pulls away as the, uh,
by the way, Whitney canceled on me. Like
[inaudible], we've rescheduled a couple times.
Don't how she, um,
I like how she rephrased the canceled rescheduling. Okay.
And I completely understand reschedulings but I get it.
And I just wanted to say, when you did that to me, text messages,
didn't go on for too long, only six months. But I stayed strong. I was like,
all right, tell me when you have been any,
what time what's your address?
You have been in Florida. This is true for a while to be fair,
free Florida. Ah, sorry.
Half of this conversation is us talking about our ovaries.
[inaudible] to be exact. I'd been bleeding from everywhere.
So those of you that are curious, Amanda loves the voice memo.
She loves the voice memo and they put a lot of effort into them.
It's not my first take three voice memos in a row.
Not in a wait for your response. Just going to record.
And then I'm just going to get ahead of it.
I already know what you're going to say. I need to work on my patience. Yeah.
You didn't even listen to that.
Oh, he made it relatable to you. Oh,
okay. Okay. This is a reschedule. This is annoying.
I'm shooting this thing for Spotify. They're now moving it to the afternoon.
I said, I swear, I'm not this much of a flake. And she realized it.
I realized dad,
no worries, six time. But then she said,
I'll be in Florida. So then she was in Florida. That was me telling her,
you missed your chance here, girl. I'm in Florida.
Now this has been going on for a while. Also.
Another thing about Amanda that you guys should know,
she puts a space at the end of her sentences before punctuation
punctuation. It's a Spanish keyboard.
That's a psychopath. I all blame auto-corrects. I hope everything is okay.
Space. Exclamation, Mark. Exclamation, Mark. Look at this. Why do I do that?
Period?
I know November 15th of last year,
a picture of the mask.
I think I'm going to edit this video down and then just keep rescheduling it.
Yeah. Cleanse and dry face before. Now that
time. Wow. Okay. Let me get you in the gym.
Maybe do some tricks. Suspect, intense tightening sensation.
Should I put this on my life?
Hack slide, close to under eye area.
You made experienced gradual pulling effects. Don't be alarmed.
Don't be alarmed to. Upwards to lift cat.
How old is this crusted?
Over plume of dust.
Don't make your teeth. They got it. No. Okay. That's done then. No,
we do that. You know what I mean? I don't know how to explain what I just did.
It's like peeling all the metal online. Do you want me to do it? Yeah. Oh,
I didn't expect you to take me up on that. And you're mad at me.
Are you typing very me too. Yeah. I can tell
by how well you organize your resentment towards me.
If you know I'm typing, when you reschedule on me, I know
[inaudible]. If there wasn't a pandemic, it would have been a little different.
Yeah. You're going to use COVID as your cause. I have like a good six months.
Okay. There. Okay. There's my empathy. Yeah.
I would say that was a raw there's my empathy.
There was my empathy for you. Excuse me. Wait. Okay.
We both have these out now. See, I actually am type a,
I really do want to get this right. You're a robot.
Um,
you know those balloons in front of car dealerships that start low and then they
go up. Just let me know if my notes pop this off.
I think if her nose starts bleeding,
I'm not going to tell her I'm on your guys aside. I'm going to let it bleed.
And it's going to be amazing. I promise not to tell her.
I've never seen my nose bleed. You're welcome.
Lubricant poor for all the ways.
It's been a while for Whitney guys.
[inaudible] real people talk. I'm not a beauty influencer.
So I do not think you just fine. Your blood is all over my floor.
It's honestly the least gross thing that has come out of your body in my house.
Okay. But you know, and then we going really slow. I know I'm really am,
but I know. I know. I know I'm not a bad idea. I mean,
I know, but you skid star, you, you stay in your lane
and you could do better at this. You are typing eight,
nine, 10, 10 seconds behind me. I know that's a good thing.
We put a towel here. Well thought out on your end. I'll give you that.
Thank you. I appreciate that. We have the same table and the same dresser.
I feel like we're we do,
but I feel like I should paint yours with yours because I feel like yours is
better. Yeah. You know what I mean?
That's not minimize facial movements to McAfee,
my challenge or a robot. This will be easy for you. Swivel. Get that swollen.
Oh my God. You are.
If you avoiding the chair. Well, I it's fine.
It'll cover up the blood from your nose.
It's great makeup remover as well. It's all coming off.
[inaudible] do I look like I'm
[inaudible] with your face? I do not want to, if this,
I would rather take one for the, I posted a photo with, um,
out makeup before and people were shocked. So that's fine. What happened?
You should wear makeup. No, they did it. No, it's fine. It's the internet.
Yeah, that's just flirting. Okay.
She catches it with her boots thing. Is it landed on your towel?
And then you put your boobs on. I'm just trying to, I'm just trying to make, Oh,
entice your audience over to my Instagram.
Even on my Instagram. I really have, after we met,
I followed you, which is a big thing for me.
Didn't even meet you. Normally I follow and on mute.
I did shave my mustache today. That's good.
I didn't think we would have been better off taking
[inaudible]. Why are you looking at me? Hysterically? Laughing.
I don't know what I look like.
[inaudible] like, I'm like a stalactite or a stalagmite
do I just look like a sad beehive, right? Hurry up.
Because it's going in my mouth. Yeah. Okay. Hurry up.
Did your fans know how type you are? I don't think so. Yeah. It's a little,
like, it looks a little like curdled. Yeah. Like cottage cheese. That's right.
It does look like, um, a load of load.
This actually looks good on you.
It doesn't look as crazy as it seems to have on me.
I do think this is expired.
I don't think it's supposed to have these little chunks.
I feel like that's nose. I didn't.
I want your nose to age faster than the rest of your face. It was too young.
Sabotaging me. I don't know how you're from Florida and you're such good skin.
I don't go in the sun. I'm super white now. Then make them
[inaudible] you know what I like about us? We're a forceful. Yes.
And we're very honest with each other right away. And uh, moving forward.
You're not allowed to have other girlfriends. I get it.
My love is so all consuming that you won't really need other friends.
That's good though. Yeah. It's not like a ton of ton of ton of friends.
You won't have any after this. There's no like resentment. Yeah.
I mean you can call each other out on things. Are you talking about,
I feel like that me.
No, no, no. I really, if I was going to, if I drop it,
you he'll know. I'll feel it. I'm trying to win this. Right.
I'm trying to win this video. I'm trying to break. Okay.
We can't smile. Okay. How do the Housewives do it?
Aren't you supposed to fill them up?
He is getting crackly.
Feel it tightening.
I'm just going to move a little bit to make it less chunky to look like I had
such high expectations for this. I know this has been set 30 minutes,
so, okay. Let's just, I don't think it's supposed to have chunks.
I think we need to write a Yelp review. Hey guys,
you need to make your product work for people that reschedule for eight months.
How long did you shoot it?
What did you just ask me? Like how much footage do you have?
Like it's like an hour. Have you told everyone how you like taught yourself?
How to do all this stuff? Probably on like other people's stuff,
but none of my stuff, your fans don't even know how you did started this. No,
they might. If they seen the different interviews and stuff, but I am.
So I'm not a sincere moment that you're probably gonna edit out and that's fine.
Send it to me from, by channels. I am so important. Do you use these?
No, I didn't cut it off. This is bothering you. I just said, okay,
you're starting to look old. It looks like what?
My makeup looks like every day here in Los Angeles.
My freckles are way more prominent than your freckles, but I like them.
I think they're sexy. Thanks. There are. These little ones are cute. Yeah.
I have a ton of breast cancer.
This is getting tighter and tighter is really starting to constrict my facial
movement. This one freckle, like right here. And then it came,
came out of nowhere. HR. Oh my God.
Yeah, this is okay. This is what's supposed to do.
Where's the mall. It's like right here where my sweat is. Right?
She is by the way, swampy. She's a swampy lady.
A lot of people don't know that about certain areas. Jesus
temperature. Wouldn't he keeps her house because the air,
I do think the air is clean. You almost messed up my mask.
Oh, now it's messed up. It was so perfect before. Yeah.
It makes it feel like you're um, snatched. What's that mean?
Like snatched your wig, like a snatched waist. A snatched face.
Snatched. I don't know. I heard somebody else say it. Yolo. No
cool beans. I like that. That back.
I don't think I ever left. Really? Yeah.
I think divorced men with Bachar protector. Wow, cool beans.
Yeah. If I was on a date with a guy and he's a cool dude, I would be like, ah,
I'm gonna be a bummer. Yeah. It'd be a good name for a vegan restaurant.
Cool beans. It's funny. How like depends on what it's for. You know,
what about I would go to cool fears. Is that still happening? Yeah. Fierce.
You hear that on Netflix? All the time. Johana sometimes says like, my boy
is English as a first language. No, that's why that's a very European. Yeah.
Yeah. Isn't it though. Yeah. It's like my boy,
my boy. Yeah. Yeah. This is why YouTube does get canceled.
I just realized I'm in comedy. So it's like slightly different. Oh, that's good.
Yeah. How was that? How's that the worst interviewer
[inaudible] when you transcribe something or, you know,
take a clip out of context when you're not watching the whole clip or you don't
know the person's previous work or, you know,
you just see something completely out of context.
It's probably easy to pathologize it or just anything out of context,
not even comedy. It's just like, take something out of this clip.
I know nothing about this person. You haven't seen any of their specials.
You haven't looked at all their tweets. This is what they do, you know? And um,
feel like I'm frowning at you, but I know. Why are you mad? Are we gonna fight?
You're a different person. Oh my God.
It looks so crazy. My lips are like, I know you do look like,
um, I just got like a different model.
Oh my God. This mind is different minds pulling my lip up.
That's what it feels like a soon to mine a little bit is you're like my lips
look fuller. I kind of, I kind of
look like Selena Gomez. I get that.
Your eyes look awesome. Oh my God. That's so I look sad.
You look five, this like subscribe.
Where did you find this? Who told you I'm hip?
And just hope I have my finger on the pulse.
And if nothing else comes from this video,
I am going to auction off Amanda's nose,
blood in my blood.
I know I'm going to put these on eBay and nothing.
I guess it's better that it looks like nothing worse. A really bloody one.
If you throw it in the trash,
this is what I came for. What are you gonna look like when you're old?
And we now know you're still you're behind. This is true.
This is very tight. I'm going to miss my lips. And when I watched this off,
I would look like, really? That's I better,
we have the same sinks we are weirdly similar.
You were really nice to me. Yeah.
I mean like, you know how some girls like a little bit of a diva or whatever,
and it's a set you're on often, you know? Yeah. And I think for me,
like I've been on the receiving end of a lot of that.
And I have never walked through that feeling towards, for other people to have.
And sometimes you do it by accident just because you're insecure or you're
scared or whatever women are so pitted against each other. Naturally,
I just try to go out of my way to be like, we're not doing that. Yeah. You know,
I'm a guard or something. That's up. Yeah. Oh my God.
I have blue eyeliner all over. Yeah. But I think, um,
I feel like I'm carving like a clay sculpture, but yeah,
you are nice. So there's that? Well, that's all it takes,
but also you have such a like more energy.
I feel grateful that it's off me too. Yeah.
That was fun. Worth the eight month. Wait. Yeah.